[Music]
violence is a product a service just
like anything else goes to that kid's
house
you can sell violence just like one
would sell toilet paper for example as
long as there is a demand for violence
violence providers will gladly sell the
service for a price
[Music]
except in a society like america the
government has a monopoly on violence
you can't hurt or kill another person
except in self-defense
[Music]
only the government can in fact if you
think about it every ounce of power the
government has comes down to the fact
that they can legally murder you
don't pay your taxes get fined don't pay
the fine go to jail resist the rest get
beat resist the beating eventually
everything comes down to the government
killing you
and since the government has a monopoly
on violence if there's a need for
violence in the marketplace a demand for
violence that the government isn't
meeting for example maybe it's employers
using violence to break up labor union
strikes and the government isn't doing
anything about it those labor unions
have a demand for violence that isn't
being met and when there's a demand in
the marketplace that isn't being met
because the government has a monopoly on
it and isn't doing anything about it or
because it's prohibited the black market
and organized crime will come to the
rescue because those people are the only
ones that are willing to operate outside
the boundaries of the law that was true
for prohibition the mafia made a killing
bootlegging alcohol
[Music]
it's true today with drugs drug cartels
make a killing boot liking drugs
[Music]
and it was true for labor unions in
america employers were using violence to
break up labor union strikes so labor
unions needed violence to fight back
against those employers they weren't
getting it from the government so they
turned to the only service provider that
could provide violence the mafia
and the mafia gladly provided sinking
their teeth in infiltrating these labor
unions so much that they basically owned
them weaponizing labor unions into one
of the mafia's greatest and most
lucrative weapons during their reign
this is violence as a service how the
mafia weaponized labor unions
[Applause]
we infiltrated every sector of society
from the guy on the street with the
numbers business right up to the white
house you control the unions in this
country you control the country look you
control the teamsters you got two and a
half million truck drivers you call a
strike the country stops which you call
a strike at the docks nothing comes in
and out to his we had the uh
security union right
we had we had security at nine nuclear
power plants in the country
unions turned to the mafia because they
needed violence video creators and
businesses looking to create videos on
the other hand need a lot of other
things stock videos images music sound
effects animations
if only there was a place that offered
all those assets for instant download
all in one affordable subscription well
you're in luck because that's where
storyblocks comes in today's video
sponsor with storyblocks instead of
paying per dollar like what a lot of
websites charge you get unlimited
downloads on everything you need to make
great videos so you can get the viewers
to clicks the shares you want a lot
faster basically storyblocks makes
creating great videos a lot easier and
even if you're brand new to video
editing storyblocks also offers an easy
to use video editor that lets you add
anything from their library directly to
your edit and then you can export your
video in all the popular formats to get
started go to
storyblocks.comtrend right now to sign
up for their unlimited all access plan
with the link below there is zero
commitment and you can cancel whenever
you want that's storyblocks.com jake
tran with the link in the video
description below
[Music]
if you were a skilled worker like a
taylor carpenter or blacksmith in the
19th century you were probably part of a
labor union
ah yes our meager restitution
ah the sweet smell of payday
basically a labor union is an
organization workers could join for a
fee and in exchange they would in theory
get protection from the union against
their employers lowering their wages
firing them for no reason or to protect
them from bad working conditions one way
unions can make sure their members were
being treated fairly was through strikes
krusty krab is unfair mr krabs is in
there standing at the concession
plotting his oppression the union's
leadership would organize all the
workers in a particular industry to get
them to refuse to come to work for a day
a week or however long it took to get
their message across in order for them
to go back to work employers would have
to pay up we've got to unite as workers
and demand the respect we deserve from
the boss in fact you and i should go on
strike one of the first strikes ever
recorded happened in 1768 in new york
when workers started protesting against
their salaries getting cuts suddenly
everyone saw the power of collective
bargaining and people started demanding
things like better salaries and less
working hours per day for skilled
workers unions could perform miracles
this all seemed great for the mostly
white highly skilled tradesmen but if
you were an unskilled worker like a
meatpacker or construction worker who
were pretty much completely left out it
was the 1800s and of course no one
seemed to care that coal miners or
industrial workers were being used for
cheap labor that was until the mid 20th
century came along after world war 1
america saw a huge rise in the number of
immigrant workers moving to the states
trying to escape the destruction back
home most of them were uneducated and
poor at first big businesses saw an
opportunity for even cheaper labor here
was an entire workforce willing to do
the job for a fraction of the price but
not for long those uneducated immigrants
realized pretty quickly that they were
being cheated so what did they do they
went on strike and without workers to
produce food or build machinery entire
industries came to a standstill they had
to give in to the workers demands and it
was also after world war one that
prohibition came along this changed
everything for the american mafia it
launched them into the stratosphere in
fact i would argue that the american
mafia we know today would have never
gotten as powerful as it was if it
wasn't for the government banning
alcohol they were drowning in
bootlegging cash and it gave them the
funds they needed to really expand and
infiltrate every facet of american
society for decades to come with one of
those fastest being labor unions all
this powered the union's wheeler meant
that by the end of world war ii more
than 12 million american workers were
unionized and since collective
bargaining only works when everyone is
involved when the entire collective is
involved if you were a worker in the 40s
and you weren't part of a union they
would call you a strikebreaker and you'd
be on the receiving end of a lot of hate
[Music]
employers obviously weren't exactly
happy with these strikes higher wages
and better working conditions so to
fight back they needed to find ways to
put an end to the strikes
the first strikes had come as a surprise
employers weren't expecting workers to
organize against them and for a while
there wasn't much they could do to stop
the strikes and get them to come back to
work but of course the strike
free-for-all couldn't last forever and
business owners turned to a reliable
method they could always count on to get
the job done violence
the people they brought in to end the
strikes in protest were called strike
breakers or union busters and their
methods were brutal one strike organizer
named frank little was kidnapped in the
middle of the night dragged through the
streets while tied to the back of a car
and hanged
with the no pinned to his leg that said
first and last warning all because he
had gotten more people to join unions
and for union members who just
participated in the strikes some got
arrested some got beaten up and some
just disappeared but as we all know the
only way to fight fire is with fire so
those poor and uneducated workers many
of them from italy or eastern europe
decided to turn to their own for help
the mob
[Music]
sick and tired of being beaten and
threatened because they were striking
union members decided to answer violence
with violence union leaders went out and
made deals with the mob and gangsters to
protect them from their employers and
this led to utter chaos with one guy
named jb mcnamara claiming
responsibility for a hundred bombings
against anti-union leaders across the
country
the only problem was when the smoke
cleared most of the unions realized that
once hired mobsters were kind of
difficult to get rid of what were you
gonna do kick them out intimidate them
in many cases those mobsters decide to
just take over the news and use them for
their own interests these mafia
controlled labor unions would soon
become one of their most powerful
influential weapons
[Music]
[Applause]
when the unions came knocking at the
mafia's door for help the mobster saw an
opportunity of a lifetime the two things
any good mafioso wants most in his life
is money and power and by joining and
taking over unions they could get both
by controlling a powerful union you had
number one the power to shut down and
extort businesses at your whim and
number two all those millions of dollars
being paid by union workers every month
went directly into your pockets to fund
your lifestyle to buy off more
politicians to invest in real estate and
legitimate businesses it was a cash cow
for the mafia if they weren't already
part of a union after protecting them
from their employers these gangsters
took control of the unions in pretty
creative ways think of it like hostile
takeovers but with the mafia and labor
unions they ran for office and raped
elections they bribed their way to the
top and sometimes in the most mafia way
possible they just walk into a union
meeting put a gun to the organizer's
head and say it's our union now
mobsters just simply walked into a union
put a gun to the head of a union
official and said you know it's our
union goodbye the mafia took over so
many unions that at one point la cosa
nostra had unions in every major city in
the us and what would they get from
controlling unions the possibilities
were endless
look you control the teamsters you got
two and a half million truck drivers you
call a strike the country stops which
you call a strike at the docks nothing
comes in and out
extort businesses unions were the
perfect way to extort businesses for
money or for favors in restaurants clubs
and bars with a lot of employees one of
the best ways to make money would be by
threatening to unionize the workers a
mobster would basically go to the owner
and say if you don't pay us x amount of
money we're going to unionize all your
employees or if the members of a union
plan a strike the mafia would go to the
owner and say if you want us to call off
the strike pay us x amount of money
simple
taking bribes this extortion technique
eventually became so well known that
most mobsters didn't even have to go out
and threaten anyone the bribes from
business owners would simply come in in
advance a bottomless bank account but
that wasn't all once a mobster took
control of a union he put all his
friends and family on the union payroll
and pay them crazy salaries he could
also steal as much money as he wanted
from the treasury basically using it as
his personal never-ending bank account
steal from pension funds but all these
benefits the mob got from joining unions
didn't even compare to what they did
with the union pension funds just like
treasuries pension funds run by unions
could be used for whatever nefarious
purpose that mafia had and no union mob
joint venture did this better than the
teamsters
even today the international brotherhood
of teamsters is probably seen as the
most corrupt union on earth right from
the start the organization was corrupted
and it only got worse in the 50s when
jimmy hoffa took control jimmy was
single-handedly responsible for turning
las vegas into what it is today he used
most of the teamster's pension funds to
support the building of more than 8
casinos and hotels on a strip in the 60s
including caesar's palace
unions gave the mafia a chance to expand
get richer and spread their influence
like never before it got to a point
where you couldn't even tell the
difference between unions and the mob
they were practically one in the same
think about it most labor unions and
even modern ones can be compared to a
protection racket workers pay money
every month or quarter and in exchange
they get representation and protection
in some states employees could even get
fired for not paying whether they wanted
representation or not
with all the money and power the mob got
from taking over unions it seemed like
this match made in hell was gonna last
forever but the glory days of the mafia
came to a shattering end by the 70s
[Applause]
[Music]
like all good things the marriage
between the mafia and labor unions
eventually had to come to an end its
downfall started with the introduction
of the racketeer influence and corrupt
organization act also known as rico in
1970
which made it easier to arrest mafia
bosses and not just the low-level guys
who did the dirty work
jimmy hoffa the leader of the teamsters
was sent to jail and all five bosses
from the main five italian-american
mafia families were indicted and with
everyone getting arrested the mafia code
of science was basically thrown out the
window everyone was snitching on
everyone hoping to get a better deal and
it didn't help that around the same time
unions started getting some serious
political opposition with congress
siding with employers on a lot of issues
and lobbyists spending millions to make
sure unions were weakened and completely
wiped out the face of the earth what has
seemed like an unbreakable partnership
was left in pieces
today the mafia is a show of his former
self most of the children and
grandchildren and mafia members are
going to college to become doctors or
lawyers and no one is interested in
rebuilding their parents empires and
labor unions today only 8 of salary
workers are part of a union and even the
unions themselves are struggling to
survive at the end of the day the mafia
infiltration of labor unions all came
down to the need for violence that
wasn't being filled
[Music]
but once this need was filled and the
war started changing too fast the
partnership broke down but recently over
in australia labor unions are showing
that they can still be a force to be
reckoned with the truckers shut down the
roads they stopped on the bridges they
at all at the same time they shut the
country down and within 24 hours south
wales in australia went from mandatory
vaccinations to uh non-mandatory to what
do they consider what it was uh
it has been a really long time since
we've done a mafia video i missed them
so here we are let me know if you guys
want more mafia videos in the comments
below and if you're watching this and
you're still not subscribed we make
video essays just like this one every
single week for free on the most
provocative stuff in the world of crime
like this video money power and war so
click that subscribe button you can
always dislike and unsubscribe later so
just give it a try if you want more
behind the scenes stuff then the life
kind of stuff you can follow me on
instagram at jtrend.io that's going to
wrap it up for this video thank you so
much for watching you've been awesome
i've been jake stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
[Music]
you